it's going to be metro police night
tonight at the las vegas ballpark
they're celebrating local officers while
helping out their families our bianca
holmen is live at the las vegas ballpark
what's going on there tonight bianca
hey nate well this is the start of
national police week and this is the
first lvmpd night here at the las vegas
ballpark so here's some more about
what's happening this evening so this
year national police week is observed
today through the 17th the purpose is to
honor members of law enforcement for
their service and help to the public
about their role and also help teach the
public about their role to make our
valley safer lvmb lvmpd deputy chief
yesenia yatomi will throw out the
ceremonial first pitch so that's
exciting and about a thousand officers
and their families will be in the stands
really looking forward to the
opportunity to show recognition for our
officers
who do such tremendously good work
keeping us all safe
day in and day out night in and night
out
so this is an evening for
the public
to not only enjoy great baseball but
also show their appreciation for the men
and women who wear the badge
so here are the details if you want to
come out to tonight's game at that seven
the aviators will play the salt lake
bees salt lake city bees there and then
five dollars of each general admission
ticket
will be donated to the lvmpd foundation
and coming up in the next half hour we
got more details about what they do and
how they impact our valley bianca holman
live local now
thanks so much